في فينيكس، يتعامل المستجيبون الأوائل
مع المزيد من مكالمات الاستغاثة المتعلقة بالحرارة، حيث
وضعوا هذا الرجل في حزام
مملوء بالثلج والماء البارد لخفض
درجة حرارة جسمه.
تقع فينيكس في مركز سلسلة
من الإنذارات الحرارية عبر جنوب غرب
الولايات المتحدة والسهول و  فلوريدا التي غطت
أكثر من 35 مليون شخص يوم الاثنين،
شهدت فينيكس 25 يومًا متتاليًا
مع ارتفاع درجة الحرارة فوق 110
درجات، إنها بائسة في الواقع، لا
أخرج كثيرًا وأبقى بالداخل، الجو
حار جدًا في منطقة فينيكس لدرجة أن الناس قد
احترقوا للتو  بواسطة السقوط على
الأرض، قال أحد الأطباء إن درجة حرارة
الأسفلت يمكن أن تصل إلى 180 درجة في
فترة ما بعد الظهر، ويكون الرصيف ساخنًا جدًا بحيث لا
يستغرق الأمر سوى جزء من الثانية للحصول على
حرق عميق جدًا، ومن
المتوقع أن تستمر الحرارة القياسية في إل باسو وسان.
أنجيلو تكساس جنوب فلوريدا تحت
تحذير من الحرارة المفرطة خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
مع درجات حرارة قال الخبراء إنها
قد تصل إلى 112 درجة.
يقول أحد الخبراء إنه من المؤكد تقريبًا أن شهر يوليو
سيكون الشهر الأكثر دفئًا الذي شهده الكوكب بأكمله
في التاريخ المسجل طالما أننا
نواصل حرق الوقود الأحفوري
وتوليد التلوث الكربوني ويستمر الكوكب
في الارتفاع، فسنرى
المزيد من  هذه الأحداث المناخية القاسية غير المسبوقة
غير المسبوقة
والمميتة وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض، يموت أكثر من
700 شخص بسبب الحرارة الشديدة كل
عام في الولايات المتحدة. ما هو الخطأ الأكثر شيوعًا الذي
يرتكبه الناس في طقس مثل هذا؟
الخطأ الأكثر شيوعًا الذي يرتكبه الناس هو
محاولة التغلب على ذلك  الاعتقاد
بأن الأمر سوف يهدأ فقط
محاولة التفكير، أنت تعلم أن هذا
مجرد القليل من التعرق
والقليل من الغثيان، وهذا ليس بالأمر الكبير،
يمكنك الوصول إلى نقطة تبدأ فيها
بالارتباك والخمول والتعب
وفي هذه المرحلة، قد يكون الوقت قد فات
بالنسبة لك حتى لا يكون لديك ما يكفي
لطلب المساعدة. الخطأ الثاني الأكثر شيوعًا
هو عدم التحقق من
أحبائك، ويقدم خبراء جيرانك أيضًا
بعض النصائح الأساسية سهلة المتابعة
للتعامل مع  الحرارة يقولون أنه إذا كان عليك
الخروج مبكرًا قبل الساعة
11 صباحًا تقريبًا، خذ حمامًا باردًا
بقدر ما يمكنك ارتداء ملابس خفيفة
بالطبع، اشرب المزيد من الماء وعندما يحين
وقت تناول الطعام، قم بإعطاء الأولوية للأطعمة التي تحتوي على
كمية كبيرة من الماء  فيها مثل سلطات
الخضار النيئة والفواكه براين
تود سي إن إن واشنطن